hey everybody it's Charlie we got our
first look at daredevil season 3 so
let's break it down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there's a new
infinity war blu-ray giveaway I'll name
a new winner at the end of this so we've
all been waiting for that first look at
daredevil season 3 we finally got it
this picture here was released this past
weekend and it's a picture of Matt in
the original black costume waiting
outside the newspaper here while another
person in a daredevil costume is looking
to kill somebody probably Karen page
most of you if you're at least a little
bit familiar with the born-again
daredevil storyline this is a scene
right out of that this is just a small
part of the storyline but what happens
is is Ben Urich who the person they
killed during season one is sort of the
newspaper guy in this storyline writing
about how the kingpin is a terrible
person trying to expose all the things
that he's doing
I've made mistakes in the years since I
was a boy so the TV show killed him off
during season one and Karen pages kind
of taken his place but there's a person
who's trying to expose kingpin through
the media
so the kingpin tries to get rid of them
and incriminate daredevil at the same
time and smudge his good name so he's
trying to get daredevil to look like an
outlaw himself because remember in the
Netflix show daredevil took down kingpin
but also on the other side of that foggy
and Matt as lawyers put him behind bars
and made sure that he's stay there so
kingpin wants to get Matt Murdock wants
to get daredevil this is just kingpin
using his resources to try and get rid
of two birds with one stone
get rid of daredevil is a credible
threat like if people think that
daredevil is an outlaw they won't
believe anything that he said about
kingpin no matter how rotten kingpin is
and it will silence Karen page from
alerting the city and the rest of the
people around the world through the
media about what's really going on
behind the kingpins operation so it's
all part of kingpins rise to power
because he's still in jail as the
beginning of this series but this is the
process of how he gets out and seizes
power because remember season two was
all about him being in prison it's not
like he's gonna be in prison for the
entirety of season 3 the other thing
that's going on here too is that this
actually happens relatively early in the
born-again storyline like kingpin moves
quickly he starts by trying to get rid
of daredevil and anyone speaking out
against him so he slowly goes around
town to all of Daredevils associates
that he worked with to try and put
kingpin behind bars the TV show version
is gonna be a little bit different from
the comics but right at the beginning
what happens is in the comic book
version of this kingpin gets a lunatic
from the insane asylum to dress up in a
daredevil costume and go try and kill
foggy Nelson
so remember Netflix foggy is working
with jeryn hogarth remember even though
she was doing all those drugs during
Jessica Jones season two she's sort of
the glue that holds all these different
series together
now that Rosario Dawson's character
night nurse is sort of leaving the
universe for a little while just because
the actress rosario Dawson wanted to go
spend more time with her family in real
life so if you wonder why there's no
night nurse in any of the future seasons
for the foreseeable future that's why
but that doesn't mean that she'll never
come back she's still alive in the
universe part of the problem daredevil
has in dealing with some
these threats in addressing kingpins
moves against him is is that everybody
believes that he's dead
so right here where he's wearing the
black costume Karen page foggy all these
people they don't know that he's around
and because they believe he's gone that
also means that on the other side of the
coin Matt Murdock is gone he's the one
that provided all that evidence for
kingpins trial kingpin finds out his
real identity uses that against him
while he's trying to take down daredevil
and Matt Murdock at the same time so if
Matt Murdock is the person that has all
this evidence in court against kingpin
and he can't actually physically appear
in court that makes a lot easier for
kingpin to get off the hook so he's
fighting Matt Murdock in court using
knowledge of his secret identity in the
idea that he's supposed to be dead and
can't be around so the whole reason why
he's running around in the black costume
there was some set footage I think a
little while ago that lead to that to
where it was just him in an alleyway in
the black costume so everyone was
wondering why he was wearing that
instead of the regular costume it's
because when these scenes are happening
kingpin has already used sort of the
lunatic version of daredevil that he's
fabricated to make daredevil seem like a
criminal in the news so everybody is on
the lookout for daredevil the police are
ready to arrest him on sight so it's not
safe for Matt to be a vigilante wearing
that red costume which is why he has to
go back to the black one until he clears
his name so don't be surprised if he's
in that black costume for most of the
series now there's gonna be 10 episodes
of iron fist we don't know if there's
gonna be 13 episodes of daredevil season
3 or if it'll just be 10 as well because
it was this whole big thing about people
wondering why it's always 13 episodes
regardless of how much story they have
to tell the reason why is because
Netflix bought 13 episodes per season
for a certain number of seasons for all
these shows so regardless of how much
story each of the show's had to tell
they had to deliver 13 episodes but it
sounds like that recently changed with
the new deal that they signed recently
so that's probably why there's only 10
episodes of iron fist which i think is
better like 10 episodes is a solid
number you don't have to worry about too
much filler pacing isn't as big of a
problem so you get to that payoff a
little bit quicker
the thing about bullseye though is that
it sounds like the Netflix version of
the character is going to start out in
the FBI so in the comic book version of
events
was the character remember he was the
guy that took the pills during Jessica
Jones season 1 in season 2 to get
stronger
so he was a character during this
born-again storyline eventually because
kingpin has failed to take down
daredevil he uses military contacts to
get a hold of these people that control
nuke to send him into action to just
legit go after daredevil and he goes
completely crazy he goes on this killing
rampage so daredevil has to eventually
take him down it sounds like in the
Netflix version of events they're gonna
substitute bullseye for the new
character which i think is a huge
upgrade anyway but you get the idea
kingpin goes to regular law enforcement
to try and take him down but you can
understand why the FBI would be going
after daredevil because one he's a
vigilante so that already kind of puts
him on the [ __ ] list of the authorities
if he hasn't signed the sokovia accords
remember Luke Cage all these are the
people they would have had to sign those
after Captain America Civil War so then
on top of that you have kingpin using
these fake versions of daredevil to
really make it seem like he's a criminal
maybe killing people then the FBI would
really want to get their hands on him so
that's probably why this TV version of
bullseye first starts going after
daredevil but then I think we're
expecting him to become more of
comic-book bullseye by the end of the
season with more of a villain spent
[Music]
so starts out as a good character and
through his actions and his connections
with kingpin probably goes a little bit
nuts then becomes full-blown mercenary
going on kingpins payroll by whatever
future season that he appears in just
expect them to give bullseye the same
really big character arc that they gave
to kingpin during daredevil season one
like it took a while to develop the
Wilson Fisk character so just expect the
same treatment in pacing for the
bullseye character let me know in the
comments though what are you guys most
hype about as for release date I've
already done a couple videos about that
it's looking like November December but
if we get any hard dates or any
confirmations about that I will totally
do a video congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Austin Bertram please
email me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for the brand new Avengers for
Doctor Strange sequel news and click
here to rewatch that iron fist season 2
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight